У нас проблема у тому, що до Олега не допускають незалежних лікарів.
І все, що ми знаємо, - це зі слів Олега. А він, відповідно, знає лише зі слів тюремних лікарів.
Але можна сказати, що 145 днів голодування без наслідків не минулися б ні для кого.
Коли до Олега хотіли застосувати примусове годування,
було зрозуміло, що справа дуже і дуже погана.
Безумовно, він вийшов з голодування з доволі серйозними втратами для здоров'я.
Поки ніхто не може сказати, чи зможе він цілковито відновитися.
Він нажив собі ішемію, аритмію - це лише те, що стосується серця.
Зараз ми спілкуємося за допомогою листування.
Коли адвокат був у нього, я передала листа.
Зараз, коли повернуся до Києва, то напишу звіт про поїздку сюди.
Психологічно він ніяк не змінився.
Як не дивно, за ці чотири з половиною роки він все той самий Олег. Він жодним чином не змінився.
Як на мене, його в принципі нічого не може зламати.
Працює дуже активно. Не жаліється.
Але якщо Олег жаліється, це означає, що все не просто погано, а катастрофічно погано.
Адже він не з тих, хто буде нити та жалітися на долю.
Я не думаю, що у тому місці, де він перебуває, така вже велика різниця між в'язницею і лікарнею.
Скажемо чесно, і там, і там все дуже погано.
Я поки не знаю, які у нього плани. Зараз він активно працює.
Чи буде він ще раз вдаватися до такого кроку? Я сподіваюся, що ні.
Скажу відверто, це дуже страшно. Страшно за нього. Поки він нічого такого не висловлював.
Звісно змінить. Як мінімум, це приверне увагу до теми Олега.
Але не лише Олега, але й інших українських політв'язнів, яких з 2014 року вже більше сотні.
Я сподіваюся, що політики побачать в Олегові
не просто прізвище чергового політв'язня у Росії, яких там дуже багато.
А побачать людину і почнуть якось більш активно шукати важелів, як вирішити цю ситуацію,
знайти інструменти тиску на Путіна, щоб витягнути Олега. І не лише Олега.
Я намагаюся зайвий раз не сподіватися, а просто робити те, що виходить,
що я можу, що можливо, на що вистачає сил.
Але я чомусь вірю, що епоха Путіна все ж не протягне ще 15 років.
Ну досить уже! Ну повинен же бути якийсь кінець!
Я дуже сподіваюся, що санкції, а також інші міжнародні заходи
посприяють швидшому завершенню всього цього.
Чесно кажучи, я би більше раділа, якби Олега навіть не номінували на цю премію.
Свободу не замінить жодна премія у світі.
Краще б він був на волі, виховував своїх дітей, знімав кіно та не отримував жодних премій,
ніж ті умови, в яких він зараз перебуває.
Безумовно, я дуже вдячна, бо ця премія - одна з цеглинок у боротьбі за звільнення Олега.
І не лише Олега, я не втомлююся це повторювати.
Ми боремося не лише за нього, боремося за всіх українських політв'язнів.